the Joe Rogan experience um so you were
talking about Minnesota and your talk
here
yeah and then I went back east and then
I was in the restaurant industry for a
long time so basically I was in rehab
and then I left rehab and did you start
writing I always wrote you always wrote
did you always publish things like one
no I didn't know that you just do I
started writing I mean my journal holy
[ __ ] from that first rehab have you ever
seen that movie se7en where he's like
that's what my journal is Christ like
why am I still single
that movie still [ __ ] with my head I
saw it in a theater and I remember
driving home thinking I was gonna get
murdered and that was Kevin Spacey yeah
I'm just realizing that now yeah being
creepy as [ __ ] yeah but one of his most
brilliant roles well American Beauty was
another one you think I think oh god I
hate saying this you think when it
deserved it I don't think I wonder how
[ __ ] up you have to be as a human to
be able to play someone that [ __ ] up I
know I know
go to that place yeah not just to go to
that place but you [ __ ] believed it
hook line and sink yeah yeah okay like
the Joker Joaquin Phoenix I [ __ ]
bullet I haven't seen yet spoiler alert
I know no it's fine it's been two weeks
I know well I mean I'm not gonna spoil
it but it was a dark week for me I
couldn't go see it I wasn't emotionally
strong enough well just because of some
[ __ ] that happened that was crazy that
triggered all this stuff from when I
that we would started this conversation
I was like ya know as crazy it was like
a crazy PTSD is real you know I hate I
hate that the word triggered has been
destroyed like it's been destroyed
because it does when you have had trauma
and there's a brilliant book the body
keeps the score and he talks about how
it lives in your body basically and you
and he worked with vets and you know
it's crazy like he in this book I've
been rereading it again and he's talking
about how
when he was writing to get some from the
VA to get like a grant to study PTSD
they were like no we don't even really
think it wasn't even part of their
profile which is crazy to think now that
she wasn't it wasn't even like a thing
it was a brand-new shot it was yeah my
grandpa I mean I have all my grandpa's I
should have brought some back my all my
grandpa's letters from World War two I
mean that guy it is it's correct he
would be getting bombed basically going
on getting underway every single day for
months and he's like the most striking
thing to me is how he's like I don't
want to feel sorry for myself
I know nobody would want me to feel any
self pity I'm like we live in the
biggest [ __ ] generation of the entire
we live in just the whiniest culture
he's literally at war and he's like I'd
hate to be whining like why we have such
a whiny cultures because things are so
safe relatively yeah I do definitely
because the people that are complaining
for the most part the people that are
egregious ly complaining they don't have
real issues it's just so weird I always
see this like I am fighting for my life
and like no you're not you're [ __ ]
your couch getting postmates your your
your story like when you tell your story
like that's one of the stories that like
legitimately makes you sit back and go
holy [ __ ]
okay those stories nobody gets upset at
you yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a little
mean they don't get upset that it
happened to you I mean they don't get
upset at you expressing this like it's
some horrible disastrous event your life
because it clearly is well yeah and and
it is that's why I hate that the word
triggered has been so destroyed because
it is a thing that people have to end so
in this recent this girl is my hero and
this recent thing that happened it was
like this person walked in into a
situation and she looked a strut and
like long story short we ended up at a
rape trauma center together and it was
you said she walked into a situation
it's like we're it's hard to she gave me
permission to like talk about this if it
came up and and so I'm okay with it just
don't say her name no
no and I know I'm not telling her story
no details of hers um so I was in a
12-step meeting and she kind of walked
in and looked too strong I'm not one of
those girls like hey look it like it's
not like leave me the [ __ ] alone but I
saw the look s is where I might actually
cry
I saw the I recognize that look like it
wasn't like I'm having a bad day in
sobriety it was like something happened
and I just made a beeline for her and I
was like are you okay and she was like
no I'm not
and she's like something bad happened to
me and we went left that there and then
we went out onto a bench and we're I was
like how old are you and she's like I'm
19 and young you know and and I was like
she told me what happened and something
bad had happened the night before and I
was like well and I told her I shared
with I was like that same thing happened
to me at your age and I was like and
she's like what you know like that look
of like relief that somebody could
understand and she's like what do I do
I'm like well I know what not to do and
it's nothing so and I'm telling you it
was it was like that girl is so brave T
I'm like what compelled you to even walk
into that into the meeting what come I
wasn't even going to go to that meeting
and then when we ended up in that Center
like the counselor was so amazing the
nurse was so amazing every it was like a
warm blanket of love was just wrapped
around her and was she in sobriety it
was like I can't it's like not really my
story to tell but it was um she was she
was [ __ ] up yeah so um it wasn't like
dead sober but um yeah so it was just it
was basically like my story that she was
telling so it triggered like oh it was
weird to hear my story as she's relaying
it and I'm having like flashbacks so
last week I was like I haven't really
told anyone I'm even gonna like talk to
you or anything because some of my
friend was like so what have you been
doing to like get ready I'm like what
I've been crying a lot and eating a lot
of cake
they're like yeah like it's just Joe in
a conversation but I think people think
it's like it you know some people it is
yeah things get weird with people when
when there's an event coming yeah well
and it was my anniversary of six years
which always is like that was Friday
so um it was me you know it was
amazingly healing like to what to be
able to just it was one of those moments
where there's there's where something
bad that happened to me I was like oh
suddenly this has meaning like I can use
this to help someone else and that's you
know I've interviewed this really
brilliant woman who escaped from like a
million things and her whole thing is
like if you what good is our freedom if
we can't use it to liberate somebody
else and you know come circling back to
like the world war two in this
generation ayaan Hirsi Ali says that
basically this generation is like
they're like trust fund babies with
freedom because they're so far removed
from having to fight for freedom that
they just take it for granted that's an
interesting way of describing it yes fun
babies with freedom that's a and she's
just brilliant she is brilliant that is
a that's that's a great way to look at
it too but it's very hard for people um
without struggle I think people don't
know what to do yeah and they they
create problems that don't exist
[Applause]